descargando 1.6 miles de millones de toneladas de alimentos
que se estropean de camino al mercado
o caducan en nuestras neveras
o que son desechados por supermercados y restaurantes
al final del día.
Cada año, hasta 600 millones de personas
enfermarán por comer alimentos contaminados,
destacando nuestro reto de mantener la seguridad alimenticia mundial.
Y, quizá como era de esperar,
la industria agrícola
es la mayor consumidora de agua dulce,
representando el 70 % del uso mundial.
Ahora, estarán aliviados al saber
que la industria agrícola
y los movimientos globales llevados a cabo por universidades, empresas y las ONG
están haciendo una investigación a fondo
y desarrollando tecnología novedosa
para enfrentarse a estos problemas.
Y muchos lo han hecho durante décadas.
Pero una de las innovaciones más recientes en la producción de alimentos
que se utiliza en polígonos industriales de EE. UU.,
en núcleos urbanos de Asia
e incluso en desiertos áridos de Oriente Medio
es la agricultura en ambiente controlado.
Agricultura en ambiente controlado es una forma elegante de decir
agricultura a prueba de clima o ambiente,
y muchos de esos cultivos producen alimentos tridimensionalmente en estantes,
al contrario de las dos dimensiones de los cultivos tradicionales.
Este tipo de producción de alimentos también se conoce como
cultivos verticales de interior.
Estuve involucrado en el cultivo vertical interior
durante los últimos 5 años y medio
creando tecnología para que esta clase de producción
sea más eficaz y sostenible.
Esta fotografía se tomó desde el exterior de un contenedor abandonado
que convertimos en un cultivo de interior
y después lo llevamos al corazón y al calor de Dubái.
El cultivo vertical de interior es un fenómeno relativamente nuevo,
en términos comerciales,
y la razón es que a la gente le importa la seguridad alimentaria
y la procedencia de sus alimentos
y que también la tecnología necesaria para que esto sea posible
es accesible más fácilmente y tiene un coste menor,
y el coste total de producción de alimentos está aumentando mundialmente,
provocando que esta producción sea más competitiva.
Así que si desean levantar un cultivo vertical de interior
deberán sustituir algunos de los elementos tradicionales del cultivo
con sustitutos artificiales,
empezando con la luz solar.
En cultivos verticales de interior
la luz natural es sustituida por luz artificial como lámparas LED.
Aunque se usan muchos tipos diferentes de lámparas LED,
las que pusimos aquí
se llaman "lámparas LED de amplio espectro",
óptimas para el tipo de vegetales que cultivábamos.
Además, para maximizar la producción en un espacio concreto,
los cultivos verticales de interior incluyen estructuras de estanterías
para cultivar vegetales verticalmente,
y en algunas instalaciones grandes
apilan su producción entre 14 y 16 pisos de altura.
Ahora muchos de esos cultivos son hidropónicos o aeropónicos
lo que significa que en vez de tierra
utilizan un material sustituto como esponjas de poliuretano,
sustrato biodegradable
e incluso materiales inertes como perlita y bolitas de arcilla.
Otra cualidad única de estos cultivos
es el uso de una fórmula nutritiva concreta
que circula y se recicla en toda la instalación,
y esta se bombea directamente a la raíz de los vegetales
para su crecimiento.
Y, por último, estos cultivos utilizan
un circuito sofisticado de monitoreo y automatización
para aumentar de forma notable la productividad,
eficacia y consistencia,
y dichas herramientas otorgan el beneficio extra
de que producir alimentos sea más trazable y seguro.
Algunos de los beneficios evidentes de producir alimentos de este modo
son que puedes tener producción vegetal todo el año,
calidad constante y previsible rendimiento del producto.
Otro beneficio importante
es el gran uso eficiente de los recursos,
en especial el agua.
Por cada kilo de vegetales cultivados así,
se ahorran cientos de litros de agua en comparación con el cultivo tradicional.
Y junto al ahorro de agua
también se ahorra en el consumo de fertilizante.
Un cultivo con mayor rendimiento
produce 350 veces más alimentos por metro cuadrado que un cultivo normal.
Y la impermeabilización
supone un control total de nuevos contaminantes y plagas,
eliminando por completo el uso de pesticidas químicos.
Y para no equivocarnos,
estos cultivos pueden producir enormes cantidades de alimentos,
con una instalación grande
que produce 30 000 piezas de vegetales al día.
Sin embargo, como con cualquier nueva tecnología o innovación
hay algunos inconvenientes.
Como podrán imaginar,
producir alimentos así puede ser muy intensivo en energía.
Además, estos cultivos solo producen una pequeña variedad de vegetales comerciales
y el coste total de la producción todavía es bastante alto.
Y para tratar estos problemas,
algunos de los cultivos más grandes y sofisticados
están haciendo importantes inversiones, comenzando por la eficiencia energética.
Para reducir el alto consumo de energía,
se están desarrollando lámparas LED de mayor eficacia,
para crear láseres optimizados para el crecimiento del vegetal
e incluso se usan cables de fibra óptica como estos
para encauzar la luz solar directa a un cultivo vertical de interior
durante el día para reducir la falta de luz artificial.
Además, para reducir los costos de contratar mano de obra más sofisticada,
más urbana y más cualificada,
se usa mucho robótica en automatización en instalaciones a gran escala.
Y realmente nunca puedes ser demasiado eficiente en recursos.
Levantar cultivos verticales de interior dentro y alrededor de núcleos urbanos
puede ayudar a acortar la cadena de suministro agrícola
y puede ayudar a mantener el contenido nutricional de los vegetales.
También hay desiertos alimentarios en muchos países
que tienen poco o ningún acceso a vegetales nutritivos,
y mientras este negocio evoluciona,
será posible proporcionar un acceso más equitativo
a vegetales de gran calidad, altamente nutritivos
incluso en las comunidades más desfavorecidas.
Y, por último, y esto es muy emocionante para mí,
los cultivos verticales de interior pueden ser perfectamente integrados
en el paisaje urbano
para reutilizar infraestructura urbana libre, infrautilizada o sin uso.
De hecho, esto ya sucede hoy.
Los servicios de viajes compartidos han eliminado miles de coches de la carretera
y reducido de forma notable la necesidad de aparcamiento.
Este es un cultivo que pusimos en el centro de Pekín
en un recinto de un aparcamiento subterráneo infrautilizado
para producir vegetales para los hoteles cercanos.
La infraestructura sin uso
no se limita solo a proyectos de ingeniería civil a gran escala,
también comprende espacios más pequeños como rincones de restaurante vacíos.
Este es un ejemplo de un cultivo que sembramos
directamente en la pared divisoria de la entrada a un hotel
para producir hierbas frescas y microplantas in situ para los cocineros.
Francamente, si miran a su alrededor,
encontrarán espacios sin utilizar por todas partes,
debajo, alrededor y dentro de elementos urbanos.
Este cultivo lo sembramos en un rincón de oficina vacío
para producir vegetales frescos para la plantilla en cafeterías cercanas.
Puedo ser parte de todos estos proyectos geniales
y trabajar en la industria agrícola
para mejorar el acceso y la asequibilidad
a los productos frescos y nutritivos;
con suerte pronto todos podrán estén donde estén,
esto ha sido la mayor alegría y también el desafío
más humilde e intelectual que hice nunca.
Y ahora que les he convencí de que la agricultura puede ser muy atractiva,
se sorprenderán y quedarán conmocionados
al saber que aún tengo problemas
expresando por completo cómo y por qué decidí trabajar, y seguir trabajando
en la industria agrícola.
Pero hace un par de años, hallé una respuesta muy singular
oculta a simple vista.
Verán, leí un artículo
sobre cómo tu nombre,
en especial tu apellido,
puede influir notablemente
en todo, desde tu personalidad hasta tu carrera profesional.
Este es mi apellido japonés:
Oda.
Y los caracteres se traducen literalmente
como "pequeño cultivo."
(Risas)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)